ça c'est beurk
le secret le mieux gardé de ce côté-ci
de bain tenu le pas j'admets que ça paie
pas de mine comme ça mais se tape
cailloux 30 et cache son lot de
surprises
ici la vie est géniale mais pas pour les
petites natures voyons là où beaucoup
aiment faire de la sculpture sur bois ou
du point de croix
nous on préfère un autre qu'on appelle
les courses des dragons
je suis désolé mais qu est ce que tu le
voulais
mon coeur à trappes je t'ai dit que tu
étais belle aujourd'hui
non c'est vrai or dépêche-toi pète on y
va y a une sale odeur dans le coin raté
elle te déteste toujours rustine qu'est
ce que tu fais ils vont gagner
maintenant c'est ma princesse tous ses
désirs sont des ordres dur kbc y est
enterré vivant pendant quelques heures
c'est tout avant les dragons nous posait
quelques petits problèmes cd ya cinq ans
aujourd'hui ils vivent avec nous et
honnêtement ça se comprend on a des
écuries aménagé de la nourriture à
disposition et à volonté un centre de
lavage pour driver et on a même un
système de prévention des incendies
selon moi c'est le dernier cri
quelle force c'est le moment c'est
pardonné la partie
c'est un honneur de voir ma beauté je te
souhaite un bon vol
au travail vous nomme
st
j'ai débuté
un trou va comme d'habitude
alors tandis qu un an avant ça tirait
comptant plutôt crois que ça va bien se
passer
ouais
ça
m
ingénieur
faut vraiment qu'on travaille sur ton
vol plané en solo mongrain roquemaure
alors mais des bouts alors france à
tuchan à quel point je regrette de faire
ça non non non tu ferais jamais de mal à
une jambe il est cloué au sol et c'est
loin d'être au joli les dragons et
vikings au devenus ennemis s'affrontent
dans un combat sans merci
tu sais que ça parte en lavage
alors comment on l'appelle dessous de
bras qui les mangent vendus qu'est ce
que t'en dis pour continuer